hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor i've been investing
in property for over a decade
and in this video i'm gonna be revealing
the worst property i ever
bought this is probably hands down the
worst house
it is so so bad i decided to do a video
about it now many people say to me
samuel why do you only talk about the
good side to property investing you're
talking about how to make money and how
things go well and i'm thinking to be
honest it's because
firstly i want you to succeed and
secondly
most of my properties are good and
there's very few properties that i've
bought and i've regretted buying
so i'm not going to paint a particularly
bad image i'm
just going to focus on what is the truth
however i do
think that you can learn more from bad
properties and bad experiences than good
sometimes
so if you're gonna hit the rocks and buy
a rubbish house at least be a lighthouse
to others which is what i'm being to you
right now so if you enjoy my channel
please
do smash the like button i want to see
the blue
thumb up so smash the like button also
if you're not subscribed to my channel
please do subscribe and turn the
notification bell on so you do not miss
an awesome video where you can learn
about property the worst house
i ever bought was in 2012 and
it was on durham road in durham now the
reason i bought this house was because
it was a no money down deal i
strategically creatively financed this
deal
in a joint venture partnership and my
brother holds it in his name
and i bought it for 104 000 pounds
however
the house sucks on every level it's a
little bit of an old house it looks kind
of nice and i thought this looks nice
it's no money down what could possibly
go wrong
but because it's in a bit of an old
house i've had continual problems with
things like damp
i've had the the roofs need fixing i've
spent
probably about 15 000 pounds in the last
eight years or so since i've owned it on
that property
and on top of that the house is worth
today
exactly what it was worth when i bought
it back in 2012.
so capital appreciation on it has been
pants the
maintenance on it have been terrible but
on top of that to make it
much much worse the tenants have been
terrible
that house seems to attract awful
tenants
now not the kind of awful tenants you
might think it's in a reasonably nice
area
you know it's not even nice everybody
it's not in a you know trash area with
bums and stuff
and i i've always spoke to the tenants
they've seemed lovely but they've just
never paid rent they're moving their pay
rent for a year and then they stop
paying rent and i'm like what the heck
then i have to evict them and they make
it difficult as possible it takes six
months to a victim and then finally i'm
like
ah it's over and then i move somebody
else in and the same thing happens again
so i did a calculation on on spreadsheet
on that particular property
and over the last eight and a half years
or however long it's been since i've
owned it guess how much profit i've made
on that property i have made
nothing no money in fact i've
if you add it all up with the money that
i've spent on it and the money that i've
made i'm actually down
financially right now and this is what
inspired me and prompted me to do the
video
that property is empty and i was like oh
do i even want to get another tenant
because the only thing worse than no
tenant is a bad tenant
and don't get me wrong by the way i know
i'm focusing on the bad right now
some people might say in the comments oh
just get a management company or oh why
don't you just do this or just
i've done all those things there's
always a very small
element of risk when you're buying a
property there's always a chance that a
tenant will come and they'll have
perfect references perfect credit and
then
they'll work they won't pay rent it is
possible it's unlikely but for some
reason this property just seems to have
the kiss of death on it it's empty right
now
and my wife went around to visit the
property and guess what
the old tenant has trashed the property
it is
filthy and we're gonna have to spend a
few thousand pounds getting it up to
scratch
to move a tenant back into the property
which is gonna at best make us 150 pound
a month profit
which is going to take probably about
two years to pay for the refurb of the
last tenant that trashed the house do
you know what you call that you call it
a
terrible investment so i'm really upset
about this house
i thought i'd share it with you what are
the lessons from this there's a few
lessons firstly is
just because a house is a free house
doesn't mean it's a good house it's got
to make you money it's got a cash flow
positive
at the time i was only like 20 years old
so i was growing my portfolio i was
taking on any houses that i could
now i'm more picky now i'd rather put in
10 grand
and have a good house the cash flow is
positive then put nothing in at all but
have a house it's actually potentially
going to lose me money so i think that's
the first lesson
next thing this is really important
every time you buy a property
yes there's a risk but what's going to
happen is you to have some properties
that perform
and what i mean by that is they're going
to perform as expected so if you expect
to put a tenant in
and they'll pay this and you expect the
return on investment to be say 15
percent
it's just going to perform nicely as
expected
you have some properties that
underperform
now those properties maybe there might
be a property that's prone to
maintenance or you might have to be a
bit unlucky with it but it's going to be
an underperforming property
and then you can have some properties
that over-perform and
they're going to shoot up in value and
you're going to have really good tenants
and you're going to put the rent up and
it's just going to be amazing
and you're going to make more money than
you thought now this is a really
important lesson firstly
expect that just be prepared that you're
going to have under performance
over performance and just performers
that's your portfolio it's gonna happen
now it's really important that you do
don't look at this as an overall
portfolio though now you might think
what are you talking about surely you
just need to look at the
whole portfolio as a whole yes you do
but you
also need to look at each individual
property what do i mean by this
every month i have a financial report of
all of my businesses all of my
properties and i want to see
how much have we turned over what were
our overheads what were our direct costs
and what were our
profit and what was our net profit
percentage those are the figures that i
want to know
every single month on my financial
report now my property business
i want a financial report of the whole
portfolio
and i want a financial report of every
single
individual house you need this let me
give you an example
of one of my students so one of my
students said to me samuel i've got
on when is wednesday by the way said
i've got three rent to serviced
accommodations and it's making
me 3 000 pounds a month i'm like
fantastic that's great
and you you might assume okay so a
thousand pound each i said
so you're making three thousand pound a
month off of the three houses how much
is each property making you
i'm not really sure i said well you need
to find that out
i told them about how to do your
financial reports and the figures you
need to run down
and this this student was actually a
student online academy and they went and
they and they did the financial report
and they came back to me they said
samuel guess what i said what's that
they said i'm making three thousand
pound a month from these three
properties but
one of them is making me one thousand
pound a month the other one
is making two thousand pound a month and
the third one is making me
nothing so in their mind they've got
three properties they're making three
thousand pound a month
great nice portfolio but actually
there's a weak
link in their portfolio which needs to
be cut needs to be chopped
and unless you do individual accounting
on in
each property that you have you won't
know where these weak links are
so my advice to you if you're a property
investor is make sure you know your
numbers have spreadsheets
every single month look at what your
whole portfolio
has made and what the net profit is and
the net profit percentage
but then also look at each individual
property and if you've got any weak
links
either sort them out fix the problem or
sell the property
and then or or get rid of it if it's a
rent to rent and then find another one
which is more like one of your high
performing
properties you're always going to have
low performing properties but you want
to have as few of them
as possible i hope you found this video
useful if you've got property investment
questions
let me know below i'd love to hear your
comments your feedback your thoughts and
if you enjoyed the video as i said
before
smash the like button subscribe to the
channel and turn on the notification
bell if you want to see more videos like
this you can watch a whole bunch more
here
and if you want to hear stories of
students that become successful in
property
you can do that right here and of course
you can subscribe right over here do
that now and i'll see you on the next
[Music]
video